ja der horror ist zurückgekehrt auch in
die ukrainische hauptstadt kiew nachdem
es mehrere wochen keine angriffe auf
kiew gegeben hat bzw nur auf kleinere
vororte aber nicht auf die stadt selber
gestern abend eine große explosion im
zentrum der stadt genau während antonio
guterres steuerbar wir sehen uns noch
mal an der krieg hat sich verlagert seit
anfang april der krieg der vor rund um
tiere in cerny inzumi im norden des
landes gedruckt hat ist jetzt in den
osten gegangen aber gestern abend kiew
wurde wieder angegriffen und wir sehen
uns einfach mal die minuten oder
sekunden minuten nach dem angriff an
hier ganz kurz zu sehen im stadtteil pro
deal hat sich diese explosion einige ist
also ganz in der nähe ganz in der nähe
des zentrums von christmann seht ihr
kleine parks man sich da ganz normale
wohnhäuser aber und das ist eben ein
fakt diese lisa angriff galt einer
raketenfabrik nämlich derart der
munitionsfabrik die verschiedene high
tech raketen herstellt die auch
getroffen wurde aber die sich im mitten
in einem wohnviertel befindet und aus
diesem grunde haben wir auch mindestens
einen toten und zehn verletzte die dort
zu beklagen sind und
auch ganz klar diese fabrik war nicht
sehr gestern da diese fertig ist
durchgehend da die steht da seit jahren
die die position ist bekannt und wir
wissen mittlerweile dass eine calibre
marschflugkörper der russischen armee
genutzt wurde eben genau in dem moment
wo her gute risch der un-chef dort vor
ort war um eben diesen angriff ja der
aus russischer sicht vielleicht
gerechtfertig sind aber ist aber am ende
doch zivilisten auch getötet hat um
diesen angriff durchzuführen und wir
haben ganz neue aufnahmen die wir uns
einmal ansehen wollen von menschen die
dort zu der zeit einfach unterwegs waren
es ist war ganz normal am frühen abend
es war feierabend verkehr in kiew wir
wissen es etwa ein viertel der menschen
die geflüchtet sind sind wieder
zurückgekehrt markiert mittlerweile das
heißt die stadt ist voller zivilisten
ist einfach voller menschen und wir
sehen dass hier feierabendverkehr und
wir konzentrieren uns mal ein bisschen
auf ihr rechts oben auf den rechten
oberen rand und wir sehen gleich das
hier ein auto fährt ich will es einmal
einfärben ein auto fährt von menschen
die da drin sind ein mann und eine frau
das wenn wir gleich sehen die einfach
überhaupt nicht wissen was passiert die
einfach ganz normal auf dem weg sind
durch ihre stadt in ihrer heimatstadt
und die daneben
gleich fast zu opfern werden wir sehen
gucken auf dieses auto hier oben in der
ecke und wir sehen die erste explosion
die explosion mit vor ihn statt etwa 20
meter vor ihnen die menschen dort sind
schockiert in dem auto sie versuchen
zurückzufahren wir sehen es jetzt der
rückwärtsgang eingelegt sie fahren
zurück versuchen also sich von diesem
feuer zu entfernen und kurz danach
geschieht ein weiteres unglück nämlich
vor ihnen gibt es eine zweite riesige
explosion diesmal ganz nah dran an ihrem
auto können das uns einmal ansehen das
ist also das auto man sieht jetzt wie
die alarmanlage angeht man sieht also
wie diese blinker hinten angehen das ist
einfach mal weiter laufen und wir sehen
wie jetzt und da haben die menschen
tatsächlich riesiges glück gehabt kurz
darauf die menschen aussteigen also
zuerst aus dem schwarzen auto was ihr
vorne standen hat steigen zwei menschen
aus und rennen weg und jetzt sehen wir
wie um das auto herum zuerst der fahrer
höchstwahrscheinlich der mann auf der
linken seite seine frau herausholt und
hier sehen wir die menschen die im
letzten moment also flüchten können auf
der linken seite hier der fahrer der
mann und auf der rechten seite die frau
die er vom beifahrersitz etabliert hat
mit anderen worten also sekunden die
hier über leben und tod entschieden
haben können uns ja den schein im moment
doch noch mal ansehen
die also quasi darüber entschieden haben
ob diese menschen leben oder nicht was
putin ganz klar natürlich einkaufen ja
wir sehen uns da oben in die ecke fahren
rückwärts es gab den ersten angriff und
schlägt ein zweiter kaliber
marschflugkörper ein ungefähr zehn
sekunden nach dem ersten und es hätte
hier auch für diese menschen so
katastrophe kommen können es gab einen
toten es gab zehn verletzte alles
zivilisten und insofern auch dieser
angriff natürlich terror gegen die
zivilbevölkerung
wir schauen noch einmal in den osten des
landes dort tobt die großoffensive
russlands und wir haben neue aufnahmen
auch von gestern bekommen aus der region
donetsk aus in der nähe der stadt auf
die vka das ist hier unten zu sehen darf
sich großstadt donets das istaf
tiefgang nördlich davon auch dort
versuchen die russen aktuell
vorzudringen und dort gibt es
luftangriffe der russischen armee aber
diese luftangriffe werden auf ganz
spezielle art ausgeführt nämlich nicht
mehr von oben nicht mehr von von
bombardier darüber fliegen das ist viel
zu gefährlich die russen nahmen viele
flugzeuge verloren dort in den letzten
tagen haben gesagt teilweise bis zu
sechs luftfahrzeuge an einem tag wurden
abgeschossen das hat man die russen hier
eine neue strategie und wir sehen dass
hier mal das sind zur kampfflugzeuge s25
erdkampfflugzeuge und wie sehen wie
unglaublich tief die fliegen zum einen
sind sie extrem tief und zum anderen
zeigen wir das auch noch mal haben sie
diese flairs diese täuscht körper die
sie die ganze zeit ablassen nach hinten
abschließend so dass wenn
flugabwehrraketen auch sie fliegen das
design abgelenkt werden getäuscht werden
das weiß die toys körper und dann diese
leuchten munition treffen statt die
flugzeuge aber wir sehen dass uns
einfach mal an wie unfassbar tief liegen
müssen sehen also schornsteine das ist
ein sehr industrielle gegend wir sehen
diese berge immer das sind berge sind ab
baumberge weil es gibt hier viele
bergbau das heißt also nach kohle
gesucht und diese diese berge wären dort
einfach aufgetürmt das ist das was aus
der erde geholt wurde sozusagen was
nicht kohle sondern der abraum und wir
sehen wie kurzzeitig die flugzeuge sogar
dahinter verschwinden und dann wieder
auftauchen und insofern gibt es hier
sagen wir mal eine relative sicherheit
für die ukraine weil diese erst
kampfflugzeuge nicht mehr wie sie es
eigentlich wollen auf ihr ziel zu
fliegen und dann so ungelenkten rakete
nach vorne auf das hier abschließen
sondern die fliegen parallel zum boden
wir haben das eben gesehen schießen ganz
gut und fliegen dann ganz schnell ganz
tief wieder weg um eben nicht
abgeschossen zu werden also ein wenn man
so möchte teilerfolg hier vielleicht
noch mal im letzten moment um zu sehen
wie und fast aktiv das ist das ist das
ist nochmal von jemand gesehen hier
haben wir also diese erste 25 die fliegt
nach links links an das cockpit da
direkt beiden flügel da rechts das
leitwerk und wir sehen wie wirklich
extrem knapp vielleicht 10 20 meter über
dem boden die flugzeuge fliegen müssen
damit sie nicht von denen teilweise auch
vom westen geliefert ein
flugabwehrsystem dort zerstört werden
trotzdem ist es den russen weiter
möglich dort zu fliegen dort anzugreifen
und die ukraine sagt ganz klar wir
brauchen viel mehr schwere waffen
moderne waffen womit wir auch diese tief
liegenden
erdkampfflugzeuge die uns dort weiter
angreifen auch vernichten können